hereditary was directed by airy aster
this is his first feature according to
his IMDB he has only made shorts up
until now this film stars Toni Collette
and Gabriel Byrne and is about the
history of the Graham family which as we
learned throughout the film is littered
with tragedy the film opens with Toni
Colette's character Annie saying goodbye
to her mother she's recently passed away
she also has a younger daughter a son
she's married they live in a creepy
remote house that's very large with big
open spaces a lot of great things you
can do as a horror filmmaker with a
setting like that and she has a hobby of
making miniatures and she's turned this
hobby into a career and as she's looking
in her houses and painting her dolls and
creating these settings she starts to
see things in the corners of the house
noticing things happening at night
feeling like some kind of presence is in
the house and her family starts to
notice these things too and from there
on out we have a horror film one that
we've perhaps seen before in different
incarnations but never with this level
of skill at least in recent years and
before I continue with the review I want
to make sure you guys notice stay tuned
for the end of the video because I do
have a sponsor for this video and that
sponsor is shudder I'm gonna tell you
guys about something I'm doing with them
at the end of the video and yes you're
gonna see some sponsored videos this
year because college does not pay for
itself
I wish it did but it doesn't I heard so
much about this film out of festivals
how it's the next Exorcist how it should
be mentioned in the same breath as films
like psycho and when I tend to hear that
type of praise from critics out of
festivals I I'm a little antsy about it
I approach it with a grain of salt
because I've had experiences in the past
where critics have gone insane for
horror films and myself as a big fan of
the genre I get excited and then I get
let down and I didn't want that to
happen I wanted this film to be what
everyone was saying it is so I went in
with high hopes but I was keeping them
low a little bit too like I was being
realistic from the opening shot alone I
could tell I was in the hands of a
filmmaker who has considerable passion
for his craft the opening few minutes
are creepy from the get-go and you're
not really looking at anything
particularly
scary because this film understands that
fear and horror is very subjective it's
gonna be different for everyone else you
can go to a film and be entertained by
jump scares or scary things that happen
that you expect to happen and you sort
of enjoy the fact that you know what the
movies going to be like like you're just
having a good time watching a scary film
that you basically know the ins and outs
of it all the tropes all the cliches all
the beats or you can go to a film like
hereditary and you know nothing and it's
unexpected at every single turn but fear
is subjective it's going to be different
for every audience member however I
think that most people can really relate
to family drama family tragedy something
that feels like it could really happen a
disturbed child an older child who has
witnessed something horrific that he
can't forget a mother with a family
history that goes back so far in and is
steeped in tragedy and a husband who is
just trying to figure out how he can
balance all of this and stay sane
himself and in just that sense alone I
found this movie very unsettling because
it all feels like it could maybe happen
yeah it has its supernatural trappings
bumps in the night and creepy imagery
but there's something about the core of
this movie that feels real and it
touches on things and it shows things
that are now seared into my brain and
will probably never leave I adore the
way Astor directed this film I think he
has shown himself to be a master and
this is just his first feature I walked
out of this screening and the screening
rep looked at me and was like so what'd
you think Chris and I was just like I
don't know I have to think like that was
it just blew me away i sat there looking
at the credits for like two minutes
without moving because from beginning to
end this film feels like an experience
that's just assaulting you with visceral
imagery and sound effects and an
incredible performance by Toni Collette
and if she isn't nominated for an Oscar
I actually really won't
be that surprised because the Oscars
tend to look down on genre films
although they did nominate Logan for a
screenplay so maybe they're turning over
a new leaf and she was nominated once
before for this Sixth Sense which is
also a horror drama and so she could get
it again and I think she should this is
the Best Actress performance I've seen
so far in 2018 and she's absolutely
phenomenal she's asked to do so much as
an actress to emote so much in almost
every single scene and this could be
dangerous because she could become just
too over the top but she finds that
perfect balance between realism and just
flat-out insanity because her character
has as I said a very very terrible
backstory with her family and so as
tragedies happen in this film in her
present day it's almost like she can't
really cope with it it's just too much
you know everyone has that breaking
point and Tony Colette's character Annie
she passes that breaking point by the
end of the first act and we still have
two more acts of a film and she is just
on edge for the rest of the film and so
are we because we're experiencing this
story through each one of these family
members as they watch each other
just completely break down and lose it
I'm not gonna get too much into the
supernatural aspect of this movie
because I didn't really know much about
it at all going in I'd like to maintain
that facade for you guys so that you can
be surprised hopefully by what happens
but there are things in the corners of
some frames in the shadow and he just
cuts to a wide and it's in the frame for
a really long time and you might not
even notice and if you do notice it just
sends chills down your spine there is
multiple times like that in this movie
where I just felt my entire body kind of
lock up and this is coming from somebody
who's watched a lot of horror movies and
maybe that's why this film stood out to
me so much I mean I watch weird stuff I
just went through like a phase where I
watched all these really hyper violent
French horror films like inside and
high-tension and martyrs and I've seen
some weird stuff but this movie gave me
shivers just all through my body multi
all times and it's not just because it's
like startling or really frightening a
lot of it really does have to do with
the editing and the sound design because
whenever I see something that just seems
like it was presented in the most
perfect way it sort of like fulfills
this desire I have to see a director who
understands how to make a damn good
movie and that's how I feel every time I
sit down in the theater
I just want to see a director who knows
what the hell they're doing and when I
see that it's so cathartic for me
because I feel like oh my god yes you
understand I want to talk about young
Milly Shapiro who plays the daughter
Charlie magnificent this is her first
role she was so disturbing and she sold
all of that through very little dialogue
her character is integral to building
certain scares that pay off eventually
there's a few scenes with her that I'm
never gonna forget and a lot of it
really does have to do with when you
show someone something at what point do
you choose to reveal to the audience
what you know happened but maybe we're
not gonna show it to you yet we're just
gonna have the characters maybe want to
look but no they don't want to look yet
and then there it is look at it and my
body was just like oh this movie really
got me guys
arrey Esther was clearly a filmmaker who
knows when to show you something and
when not to show you something he is
someone who understands imagination the
fact that what we don't see is going to
be a lot scarier in our minds because
we're thinking about where something is
when to show it you know when to keep it
in the shadows when to let something
just barely be seen out of the shadows
and that's something that really
bothered me there were so many moments
where like you expect there to be some
loud jolt that sort of releases you from
your from your nervousness or from the
anxiety that a scene is setting up you
don't get that you just get like the
cut to an angle of the room which at
times sometimes does resemble the many
des miniatures that tony Colette's
character was making you get these
really amazing wides that almost make
the room look like it's one of her
creations and you just see something
maybe in the corner just barely it might
be there and your eyes sort of try to
adjust to it just like the person who is
waking up from bed and kind of squinting
and is someone standing in my room dude
I'm not even kidding this movie kind of
is what we've kind of got to me I'm
thinking a lot about it I've been
thinking about it all day and I've been
thinking about this in particular in
regards to other horror films and I
don't think I've seen one that I've
loved this much since the babadook now a
lot of people don't like the babadook
and a lot of critics liked it and people
thought it was you know it's all right
or some people hated it because you know
they wanted a monster movie but that
film to me was that type of domestic
horror that I love that feels like it
could really happen that touches on
mental illness hereditary has similar
themes but it's more mainstream I would
say than the babadook was hereditary is
the perfect balance between mainstream
horror and art house horror it has all
those genre things you expect to happen
those big moments but it also has a lot
of really compelling character drama
which is the art house heart of the film
that that's trying to come out and I was
really satisfied with this film I have a
few minor issues during the second act
we made a character played by and out
who I've been praising on this channel
ever since I saw compliance I think
she's wonderful and she's terrific in
this movie too there's some aspects of
the second act that do have a lot of red
herrings where you think the film is
going in a certain direction but it
might not be a filmmaker needs to have
those moments though because we have to
understand what the film is about we
have to feel like we're on a mission or
we understand the goals of the
characters you can switch those things
up in the third act but we have to feel
like we understood what was happening
the progression of the movie and
sometimes for about 10 to 15 minutes of
that second act I wasn't exactly sure
what the movie was doing having seen all
of it though I understand the imperative
nosov those 15 minutes and so it might
just be a first viewing thing where
during the first viewing you're like
what's really happening and better than
by the end you're like okay I really see
why that was necessary there is a little
bit of exposition that goes overboard as
well
we need Annie Tony Colette's character
to let us in on some things that have
happened so that we understand just how
terrible it was and what it's done to
the family and specific relationships in
the family and I can understand that
from from a writer-director perspective
it's kind of tough to tell those aspects
of their backstory without just having
the character say it which is what we
have happened and exposition is
absolutely necessary in film it's just
that when it's only relied on sometimes
that can be a little detrimental and I
understand how important exposition is
it's necessary and I would I wouldn't
say that it's relied on there's a few
scenes that are a bit exposition dumpee
but it didn't really bother me that much
it's just something I noticed while
watching it and I feel like it's one of
those things where I just I just didn't
really I wasn't bothered by it it didn't
really bother me I didn't really care I
was so interested in the character drama
that as she began to tell this story
about what happened to her family in the
past I was just riveted because the
film's set up this character so well
that as I was watching her tell this
story I just wanted to know like I
actually I felt I felt for this
character and so that's that's how you
do exposition you know someone's gonna
tell a story make that character so
compelling that you want to hear them
tell you it honestly hereditary is one
of the best horror films I've seen in a
very long time I want to see it again
right now I can't wait to see it this
weekend
fear is subjective though as I said not
everyone's going to be scared by this
movie because you know what does scare
you and for me it's something that feels
like it could maybe happen and yeah
there are supernatural elements to the
film that are a little over the top but
you kind of
need to have that too in a film like
this because you want to fulfill the
audience's desires for for that type of
intensity but at the core of this movie
the character dramas Tony Colette's
amazing performance this is one of the
best I've seen in a really long time I'm
gonna give her Etta Terri and a I do
hope you guys check out the film this
weekend because it actually is getting a
wide release despite being an 824 film
this is one of their few films it has
gotten a wide release so you're gonna be
able to see it in more theatres so
definitely check it out as I mentioned
earlier in the video I do have a sponsor
for this video and that is AMC networks
shudder this is a fantastic streaming
service that offers nothing but amazing
horror films you have cult stuff you
have classic stuff you have weird
independent stuff I really actually was
genuinely impressed by the library some
of my favorite horror films are actually
on there
David keps stir of echoes a really
brutal and weird film I saw at TIFF
called no one lives or the most
effective shark movies that isn't jaws
ever the reef and Bill Paxton's
fantastic frailty for the month of June
they're gonna have some specific themes
that of Father's Day as well as school's
out and a lot of films that relate to
both of those themes are gonna be
streaming on shutter now normally you
can get a 7 day free trial of shudder
but with the link that I've left in the
description you can get a 30 day free
trial they have so many titles to choose
from and particularly one of their
themes this month is 30 titles they have
that Netflix doesn't have which is you
know nice little jab in Netflix so
definitely go check out shudder I think
that it's something that a lot of my
viewers will like because I love horror
and I know a lot of you guys do too so
please do check that out the link is in
description below guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]